today you're what today is saturday
right
say saturday yeah yeah i really like
today
i think the first time i seen national
saturday
it's a saturday
all right so jerry yes so we had a whole
bunch of setbacks with your apartment
and the
painting and the getting it furnished
and new clothes and all that we had
covid we had
the the rioting that happened downtown
then gary in your building who worked
there passed away from covid
yeah it's been nothing but oh boy so all
the gofundme money that we
generated for you has just been sitting
there i've been paying your rent which
is great but
but that's pretty much all we were able
to do for a long time
but but you got new clothes you got a
new bed towels kitchen stuff
new apartment all painted up
everything's all nice and new yes i
appreciate them
very much so what what's the nicest
thing about having an apartment rather
than living on the street as you were
when i first met you well you get out of
rest
you clean yourself up
you stay wars in the wintertime mm-hmm
it's great it's really good
to hang out it's your street you stay
sick of that do you get sick a lot
yeah yeah still cold yeah
little more sexual yeah
like you've been on the streets you're
not really asleep
in my case i'm really not ready to sleep
because
there's going around people you know
people walking around
you know it was great being inside so
thanks to you mark
yes definitely yeah well you become like
a mini celebrity now because of your
video
yes
inside this place here too i'm sorry
i'll be inside this place take a video
oh is that right
yeah because uh it seemed before
it asked what that place was in i said
that's the uh studio
yeah that's about it the exposures yeah
you've been inside yeah
yeah well it's nice that people now know
your story yeah yes
i think a lot of people were just
frightened by you or whatever right
right yeah yeah
yeah now they know the back story and
it's like yeah it's a good
i didn't know comedy anything i was
about i knew that was you but you know
what happened and everything like that
everything they should be sometimes like
i was building on the streets
yeah so i've come to see you many many
times now probably a hundred times
i've come over and your mood
is so consistent every single time i see
you you're in a great mood
just as you are now you're personable
you're pleasant
and you never get down from your
situation or what happened to you
don't worry about things in life
you like your temple that's the bible
it says don't worry about his life
since then when you say i want to go
come and see
i can't change this
and i was not going to see what i wanted
everybody's going to see him you know
use an excuse but i can't do that
do you ever feel like a victim no
that means so many people i talk to are
always
are telling these victim stories their
victims their victims and i never hear
that from you
a lot of people know absolutely they
know about me than i do
as we was out i broke into a house
wherever he was there and he shot me in
my face
everybody said this here there's a
uh i keep moving on
i gotta let this bring my way down
if they got it uh
i lose my mind
and that before you can take this
and you have guys out today
they don't like me for what they work is
this here they see this right here
i don't know nothing and then
they're gonna talk to me find out i'm
not what they thought i was
damn you hey man they damn you
okay they told me being like this here i
would move like this
uh i don't know nothing i've done or
whatever
in one of the streets and then they
would give talk to me
like that and you say yes i think
my favorite thing about you is you seem
to carry no anger
yeah yeah you don't seem like an angry
person at all and they get mad
to you or about the person that did this
to you i mean i think your views on
forgiveness are similar to mine
in that you forgive
for your you're doing it for yourself
not for the other person right by
forgiving the other person
you're more you're more at peace
i can't uh i'll go
i gotta go i go to show like i can't do
that though
i love life
life is life is great
definitely i think your your positive
attitude
yes this is it's like a motivational
speech just in itself so i mean
were you as positive a person before
your
shooting you were always positive yes
even when you were a younger man i love
living
i love living and
i could wait till the morning time to
come i would get up early in the morning
and see the boys at night and you had a
lot of friends yeah too many
i was
a little bit by myself a lot sometimes
most times yeah
you're about yourself a lot now yeah
yeah like the room there i sit back and
look at that radio you want me
yeah it's very helpful a lot
because i just sit in that room this
mess in my room day in and day out
nothing and then of course i got sick
and stuff
and i can't go uh this doesn't make my
thing everything
yeah it's great um work
i i gotta have that with me
you have a problem breathing yeah i i i
messed up my place too
uh for example
say say that i had a word of suffering
i could come outside for two weeks
without without your medicine well
experienced yeah
examples do walk over here
please say i did not have the stuff you
know the whole thing
we'll go here oh well we've been about
20 minutes
hm it's just like three three four yeah
they're like they're still they walk
over here it's like 20 hours
it's not gonna take two dollars about
you just getting them to take a while
yeah it takes you a long time
to stop it like uh
one time uh i was by the flower shop my
friend i used to build my first metroid
and oh the stuff that i never stuck to
me
and so i was trying to uh
figure would be better if i get to my
place
and call 911.
uh go right right right next to the the
parking lot at the corner there
five states you know that's right there
the corner i had the uh go to the friday
and then i got just right right right uh
they brought you [ __ ] about right
there when i got there
i had to bend over catch my breath while
i get to it then when i got to it i
looked at it i'm done with it i looked
at it
i was so tired and i pushed it the guys
came out
and gave me a brief stream right outside
out there at the front where it was down
this way yeah
at the fire department right there right
there yeah okay
so jerry what what advice would you give
to somebody who's
struggling with depression or struggling
with life
just just having a hard time with life
and and you seem to be
so content and happy how do you tell me
he's the first to god it's jesus i
thought you just get the faith from
jesus
he provides you away if you provide them
away
you'll by the way lots of guidance there
right yeah
they said don't worry about the things
in life
all right you just leave it here by the
way
he's like he's here
hey my case
don't worry about the things you can
change just accept it
that's the right way it says don't worry
about the things you cannot change
that's something you cannot change
yeah yeah that's beautiful work yeah
hey you're uh do you think you're biting
going
what's that you think you're putting
this way you see trouble getting elected
i don't know i don't know i don't want
to think about it
yeah i stay out of that stuff
i just go with the flow
yeah you do yeah let's go to slow
because then
it's your politicians it's quotes
all right jerry well thank you for
talking to me again thank you
and i'm happy to help you out with a new
place to live we appreciate that boy
thank you thanks
everybody and thank you to all the uh
people that donated to you yeah thank
you
thank you a lot of people donate a lot
of money to you yes thank you well you
know thanks people
yeah let me see you thanks for working
everybody too
all right next year
you